welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Nicola Nattrass a visiting professor
at Yale in the ethics politics and
economics department and the
International Affairs Council
professor Nattrass is based at the
University of Cape Town in South Africa
where she is a professor of economics
and the director of the AIDS in society
research unit her researching interests
include unemployment and economic policy
in South Africa the political economy of
antiretroviral treatment aids policy and
AIDS denialism in South Africa she has
written numerous scholarly articles and
several books including the moral
economy of AIDS in South Africa and
mortal combat AIDS denialism and the
struggle for anti retrovirals in South
Africa today we'll talk with her about
her AIDS research
welcome professor an address that's the
pleasure you are an economist how did
you become interested in aids policy
that's a it's a good question because it
was a very personal experience that got
me interested in aids policy that
although it was very clear by the late
1990s it's a letter who was in the grip
of a huge AIDS epidemic it hadn't really
sunk into into my consciousness as an
important academic subject and p'tee not
one for an economist but then one day an
old domestic servant used to work for
our family came to visit and she told us
a story about how her thirty year old
daughter had died of AIDS left her with
a two-year-old hv+ grandchild and this
is a story that's repeated right across
the country but when I said and listened
to her what she was telling me was a
story about her you know all of her
investment in her daughter had just
simply disappeared because she was dead
I mean in terms of human capital
investment apart from the emotional one
and the little child was getting sick a
lot and whenever it's it failed or got
diarrhea high fevers she'd rush it off
to the hospital and she was literally
blowing through her life savings trying
to keep her grandchild alive was a very
sad occasion
but that evening I listen to the news
and there was the Health Minister saying
we can't afford to use anti retrovirals
to prevent the transmission of HIV from
mother to child and I thought what does
she mean by we can't afford it
I know that this little girl has been
rushed off to the hospital at least six
times in the last couple of months and
surely I thought to myself do much
cheaper to have just saved the life of
the child by treating the mother so that
she hadn't pass on the virus to the
child so the next day I did a few quick
calculations I phoned up some
epidemiologist some hospitals and I
figured out well you know how much would
it cost us to test all pregnant woman
and give them antiretroviral treatment
just to prevent them from passing the
virus on and then compare that with how
much it would cost for these sick
children to go to the hospital several
times over the course of their very
short lives and then die and it turned
out that it was much much cheaper for
the government to implement
mother-to-child transmission prevention
than it was to not do it and then pick
up these cases of the the grandchildren
coming to the hospital so I wrote this
letter off to the newspaper saying
what's wrong with the Health Minister of
course it's much cheaper to do this and
the order to general phoned me up the
next day and said oh could you see the
proper study that was behind my litter
and I said I'm just finalizing it and
then desperately eyes I did the study a
lot more thoroughly and pretty much the
numbers were the same thank goodness and
then after that the treatment action
campaign got hold of me and said would I
be part of a court case to try and force
the government to run our treatment and
I was and after a couple of years of
struggle we succeeded in forcing the
government to change its its policies
and to in fact roll out treatment so for
me that was an accident really an
emotional investment which then turned
into a piece of academic work and
activism and then it structured my
career in for the next couple of years
because in a once I was on this kind of
AIDS bandwagon I couldn't really get off
it okay so why do you think the
government would say they couldn't
afford to when that really wasn't the
case that that started to bother me also
first of all when I made that when I did
that initial study I thought they just
simply were
mistaken they weren't thinking about the
costs that they were saving they were
just looking at the direct cost of the
program so initially my first work was
almost educational well if you take a
broader set of costs into account then
it makes much more sense but over the
years the cost of antiretroviral
treatment fell and yet the government's
resistance to using it either for mother
to child transmission and prevention or
for the general population just remained
really strong so I began to think that
it wasn't about a misunderstanding of
the economics that there was something
else going on something to do with ideas
something to do with politics okay and
what did you discover well that's when
we look at the history and that was
really the the impetus of my second book
which was on the struggle for antibiotic
treatment and what I then discovered was
that the power of ideas was much more
important and that the key thing that
lay behind the government's refusal to
roll our anti-retal treatment wasn't a
misunderstanding about the costs it was
actually the president then Thabo Mbeki
he bought the idea of a bunch of aids
denialists from america and australia
who have been arguing since the late 80s
that HIV does not exist or if it does
exist it's harmless and if you have it
you certainly shouldn't take anti
retrovirals because that'll make you
sick it's so it's a really interesting
group of theories that are not
necessarily coherent but they fall under
this rubric of AIDS denialism and they
tend to be believed by people who are
super skeptical of science and super
suspicious of pharmaceuticals and they
manage to reach out to Thabo Mbeki and
convince him that he should not be
rolling out the treatment and him and
his health minister really resisted at
every point they could so the history of
AIDS policy in South Africa is really
interesting it's really a fight between
the AIDS activists and the AIDS
physicians and the scientists to say hey
we've got these fantastic therapies that
can prevent children from getting HIV
and can make help adults live much
longer productive lives
and to sort of a rail the games that was
the state saying no and politically it's
interesting also because it wasn't just
the whole state it was Tom and Becky
personally and his Health Minister
personally whereas the rest of the
cabinet and most of the ANC were quite
baffled by it and so in the end this
huge movement from civil society
together with the scientists pushed
pushed the part of the the the
Parliament and the cabinet into
rejecting in Becky's views and his his
defeat on AIDS probably was one of the
reasons why he actually was pushed out
of the presidency early mmm-hmm
yes it is baffling how someone could
have that viewpoint today given all of
the scientific research let's talk about
aids policy in South Africa today give
us some specifics of what's going on
well things have improved dramatically
since Thabo Mbeki was deposed as
president and we've got a new president
called Jacob Zuma who the AIDS activists
were initially a bit concerned about
because he famously in a trial he was on
trial for rape which he was acquitted
and his the person who's accused of
raping was an HIV positive person and he
hadn't used a condom when having sex
with her and his his story to the press
was and to the court oh he had a shower
afterwards so that's how he protected
himself so everybody was a bit concerned
that a president who said such a silly
thing about you know showering does not
protect you from HIV what we all worried
what was he going to do about aids
policy but he seems to have to find
himself totally in opposition to Thabo
Mbeki so just as Thabo Mbeki was a
denialist he's actually been really
strong on the science and so he's had
very good advice and since we've had the
new president it's policies been much
better much clearer but you know I've
got a big legacy they're gonna have to
do work hard to to get going again and
we've got many more people on to get on
treatment and we've already got on
treatment South Africa has more HIV
positive people in anywhere in the world
wow that's an extremely big challenge so
what do you think needs to have
in order to combat that high high
percentage of people with AIDS well we
need to work on two fronts right the one
is prevention and the other is treatment
but that's kind of easier said than done
on the prevention side because you can
give out all sorts of messages about HIV
you can give people the correct
information but there's an enormous
amount of denialism that happens at the
personal level and people like to
believe that they're not as exposed to
it as as they think they are and people
are very reluctant to get tested so I I
think that the best way we're going to
get into prevention is to make sure we
roll out the treatment as fast as
possible because the more people that we
can encourage to come and get tasted and
put on treatment the more the greater
proportion of the adult population will
have that knows their status and
hopefully that will help as well also
putting adults on treatment reduces
their infectivity and so even though
adults live longer on treatment than
they would if they weren't treated they
are less likely to pass the virus on
even assuming that there are new safe
sex the whole time because your viral
load gets down to undetectable levels
when you're on antiretroviral treatment
so I'm kind of hoping that we can build
new forms of prevention on the back of a
treatment rollout but it's a huge
challenge I think we need to involve
ethnographers to help us understand more
about why people are resistant to safe
sex messaging so I assume there is
communication out to the general
population about AIDS what I'm curious
about is person-to-person is it a secret
or do people speak about having the
disease culturally how how does that
affect you know what's going on there's
a lot of stigma stigma around agency and
and so as a result people tend not to
disclose okay so the treatment action
action campaign which spent its initial
few years fighting tomandbecky of AIDS
policy is now concentrating much more
I'm trying to get people to disclose to
their families because Eric and that the
more you disclose about
I'm living positively and I'm on
treatment the better for them because
it's really bad for you if you have
secrets it's a form of stress did he
trying to mend or who knows that who
doesn't know and who's gonna find out so
it's better for people to actually be
open themselves but at the same time
it's also that those individuals could
change society's attitudes by being you
know make it clear that HIV isn't a
death sentence and that you can live and
that all sorts of people are vulnerable
to it so disclosure is an issue but
people are still resisting it and I
don't really blame them it's a difficult
thing to to admit to people mm-hmm okay
let's talk about the current research
you're doing that has to do with
denialism and conspiracy theories talk a
little bit about that what you're doing
I suppose it's still an offshoot on this
my obsession with what went wrong in
South Africa the question how could
Thabo Mbeki have have bought into these
denialists beliefs and so when I was
looking at him I got interested in how
anybody buys into these denialists
beliefs and what you often find is that
there's two kinds of ways that people
resist the AIDS epidemic the one is to
say it's harmless
HIV is a harmless passenger virus it's
caused and the disease that we see as
AIDS is caused by poverty and that's a
variety that Thabo Mbeki bought into
other people say no it is a real virus
but it was invented normally they say
it's invented by the Americans by the
CIA and it was used to try and control
the black population and linked to that
is a distrust of all medical information
because you know thought if somebody
told you that this is a weapon of war
surely people then try and protect
themselves from it you know I would have
thought that that would actually really
cause people to use to have safe sex but
no apparently what happens is there's
this general distrust of any kind of
information and link to this is a belief
also that aids is more easily spread and
if you're going to get it you're going
to get it anyway so it's accompanied by
a form of fatalism mmm-hmm so when I
started reading about this I thought
let's see why is it that they
a sense of fatalism and what who buys
into this notion that there's an evil
empire out there trying to kill you
posting there's nothing you can do about
it and how does that affect aids
prevention in it and we've done some
surveys about this in Cape Town and we
ask people questions about safe sex
behavior these are young adults from 20
to 30 mm-hmm the use of condoms and we
also asked them about their beliefs
about HIV do they believe it exists do
they believe it was created as a weapon
of war and we've been running
correlations and we find there's an
incredibly strong correlation between
people who think that HIV was a weapon
of war by a bio weapon created by
scientists in America and their refusal
to use condoms mm-hmm and so my next
phase is to try and unpack that is it
about masculinity because it's mostly
men that believers men believe in AIDS
conspiracy theories women tend to go for
the denialist view of things
so to put an anthropological work
psychological work and economic work to
try and see what's driving those beliefs
and whether we can we can learn
something about how best to reach out to
people to make sure that they do protect
themselves from HIV okay well thank you
so much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your research you're
doing wonderful work thank you very much
for more information about Professor
natura Center work please visit our
website at yale.edu backslash macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you